Brett Kavanaugh fights back with
alacrity Lindsey Graham shows his teeth
and Republicans push forward with
Cavanaugh's nomination i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
well unless we left our story on our
podcast yesterday I was very downbeat on
the possibility of Brett Kavanaugh
getting on the court because we recorded
the podcast directly after Ford's
testimony but before Cavanaugh actually
got to testify today we'll get into
Cavanaugh's testimony the overall effect
of yesterday and what comes next we'll
get into all of that but first let's
talk about your impending death so I
know you think all this politics stuff
really matters a lot and it does matter
a lot I mean it makes a difference to
your life but at some point here you're
gonna plotz and then you're not gonna
care about politics anymore in fact you
may not care about much of anything
anymore but one thing that you'll wish
is that you had gotten some life
insurance and your family mostly is
gonna wish that you'd done that so they
could pay for your expensive funeral I
mean go check it out right now at policy
genius.com right now policy genius
compares quotes from a top life in
from all the top life insurance
companies to find the best policy for
you it takes just two minutes to get a
quote some 40% of Americans don't have
life insurance which is idiotic since
we're all gonna plotz
if you don't know the first thing about
insurance they've got all the tools you
need to get you up to speed
learn the difference between term and
whole life insurance calculate how much
coverage you need be sure you're making
the right decision in fact over four
million people have used policy genius
to shop for insurance policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
home insurance and auto insurance if you
care about it they can cover it so
whether you know a lot about life
insurance or nothing at all start your
search of policy genius calm and just
two minutes you can compare quotes make
sure your family is taken care of policy
genius the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance alrighty so the big news
obviously the continuing fallout from
the Brett Kavanaugh hearings the Senate
Judiciary Committee today voting on
Brett Cavanaugh's nomination Senator
Jeff Flake has said that he will vote in
favor of Brett Kavanaugh for the Supreme
Court it looks all but assured that
Kavanaugh will enter the court it looks
also like some Democrats are going to be
peeled along with some Republicans that
mean Joe Manchin of West Virginia maybe
Heidi Heitkamp from North Dakota
it looks like Brett Kavanaugh probably
ends up on the Supreme Court by early
next week which is as it should be
because yesterday Christine Blasi Ford
gave testimony about what allegedly
happened to her 36 years ago at a party
not a single witness she has named has
verified her story from the party Brett
Kavanaugh denied it entirely and
Cavanaugh is extraordinarily fiery in
his denunciation of how the committee
had handled its business which is
perfectly appropriate remember
these accusations first came about July
30th Senator Dianne Feinstein of
California saw them she did nothing she
didn't report them to the FBI she didn't
start an investigation she didn't do
anything she didn't ask Brett Kavanaugh
a question nothing instead she just sat
on this stuff for weeks in weeks and
weeks and at the very last minute
launched the allegation in an attempt to
push this entire sham hearing beyond the
election that's all the Democrats want
here when Democrats say that they want
an FBI hearing then one an FBI
investigation what they really mean is
they want a months-long FBI
investigation that pushes them beyond
the Senate election in the desperate
hope that Republicans will lose the
majority in the Senate and then
Democrats will hold a seat open until
2021 when they hope President Trump is
defeated by Kamala Harris or Elizabeth
Warren that was their big plan here it
didn't happen yesterday and it mostly
didn't happen because Brett Kavanaugh
fought back he fought back by really
coming out strong and we'll get to the
media response to all this Democratic
response which is just egregious and
disgusting but we begin with Brett
Cavanaugh's actual comments yesterday
Brett Kavanaugh started by saying that
his life has been destroyed by the
committee has been destroyed by
allegations without a scintilla or iota
of corroborate of evidence as was
predictable and as I predicted my family
and my name have been totally and
permanently destroyed by vicious and
false additional accusations the 10-day
delay has been harmful to me and my
family
to the Supreme Court and to the country
okay so he is exactly right about all of
that and this hearing was turned into a
farce as he made clear he said this you
guys have replaced advice and consent
which would be all about the political
views of my judicial philosophy and you
replace that with search-and-destroy an
attempt to destroy my life destroy my
family and Brett Kavanaugh is exactly
right about this the reason this
resonated with so many conservatives is
for their really a couple reasons one
the media movement has been militarized
in to an allegation is made we destroy
your life not proof of an allegation not
multiple allegations not credibility of
an allegation none of that
an allegation is made we destroy your
life a mildly credible allegation is
made your life is over and there are a
lot of people conservatives and non
conservatives we're looking around and
saying that could have
- literally anyone I was talking to a
female friend last night
somebody's led a pretty rough life
actually and she was talking to me about
the fact that such accusations could be
leveraged against anyone literally
anyone I'm as I've said before the
cleanest person in American public life
when it comes to matters sexual Hey but
at one point I went over to this woman's
house with her husband for dinner she
said you know what I could say
theoretically is at you that my husband
left the room for a minute and you tried
to make a move on me right anybody can
say anything about anyone at any time
now I'm not saying that Christine
blazing Ford the accuser in this case is
completely making up the story I don't
think that she's completely making up
the story I do think that it's quite
possible that her memory is wrong but
regardless you need some sort of
corroborate of evidence and in just a
few minutes I'm gonna discuss why it's
so necessary to have corroborate of
evidence for these sorts of allegations
that's reason number one why so many
people are uncomfortable with what's
happening here reason number two why so
many people are uncomfortable with
everything that is happening here is
because for years and years and years
Republicans have been ripped as racist
sexist bigoted homophobes they have been
ripped as everything that is wrong with
society everything that is wrong with
the world and Brett Kavanaugh seems like
and his record shows him to be a
fundamentally decent person there is not
a hint not a not the mildest reference
to any sort of serious misbehavior over
the course of his life until two minutes
before he was supposed to be confirmed
for the Supreme Court and a lot of
conservatives when somebody has to stand
up in the face of this somebody has to
say no to this sort of character
assassination and Brent Cavanaugh did
that yesterday and it resonated with
people it also resonated because Brett
Kavanaugh wasn't just angry and
righteously indignant Brett Kavanaugh
demonstrated a fundamental decency even
in the midst of his anger so here was
some of his anger talking about
replacing advice and consent with
search-and-destroy this confirmation
process has become a national disgrace
the Constitution gives the Senate an
important role in the confirmation
process but you have replaced advice and
consent with search-and-destroy and of
course he's exactly right about that the
moment that really made this happen for
Kavanagh that really saved his
nomination I don't even think was him
coming out so strongly against the
committee which was perfectly a pro
rip it was when he talked about his own
family and he talked about his daughter
because this was the moment when I think
a lot of people looked at Brett
Kavanaugh and they said okay it's not
the anger is not fake be hurt and the
pain and the and the rage that he must
feel are enormous
and yet this is a guy who has the
decency to talk about with his daughter
what was going on and his daughter has
the decency to pray for the woman who's
accusing her father in his view wrongly
and and falsely of attempting to rape
her 36 years ago I intend no ill will to
dr. Ford and her family the other night
Ashley and my daughter Liza said their
prayers and little Liza all 10 years old
said to Ashley we should pray for the
woman it's a lot of wisdom from a 10
year old yeah all of this really did
save Brett Cavanaugh's nomination now
what happened next is that Lindsey
Graham came into the room and to
understand how monumental this was you
have to understand who Lindsey Graham is
the senator from South Carolina is not
exactly known for being a firebrand that
is putting it mildly Lindsey Graham is
about as milquetoast a human being as it
is possible to find a planet earth it's
one of the reasons why the Republican
base has never been fond of Lindsey
Graham they've always thought of Lindsey
Graham as the very soft-spoken gentleman
from South Carolina who sort of wanted
to go along to get along with the other
side of the aisle he voted in favor of
the nominations of Sonia Sotomayor for
the Supreme Court he voted in favor of
the nomination of justice Elena Kagan
for the Supreme Court this is a guy who
has a reputation for bipartisan work
well he came into the hearing room the
Senate Judiciary Committee hearing room
yesterday and he launched into what is
going to be seen as one of the great
all-time Senate speeches really I mean
this is one that people are gonna
remember for quite a while he launched
into Democrats and he said they have
destroyed the entire process here and it
is disgusting what they have done to
this man what you want to do is destroy
this guy's life hold this seat open and
hope you win in 2020 you said that not
me you've got nothing to apologize for
this is the most unethical sham since
I've been in politics boy y'all want
power
I hope you never get it I hope the
American people can see through this
sham that you knew about it and you help
it you had no intention of protecting
doctor for none she's as much of a
victim as you are hey it's and this was
a moment I mean it certainly was a
moment because the fact is that this was
mob justice being brought to bear
against Brett Kavanaugh and Lindsey
Graham stood up and said no there has to
be some sort of process here there has
to be some sort of corroborate of
evidence President Trump tweeted
yesterday and this was clearly I think
written by staff and was a good tweet he
said judge Cavanaugh showed America
exactly why I nominated him his
testimony was powerful honest and
riveting Democrats search-and-destroy
strategy is disgraceful and this process
has been a totally sham and effort to
delay obstruct and resist the Senate
must vote ok he's exactly right about
all this now how will the Senate vote in
the end
how will the how will the Senate vote
when it comes down to it there are some
rumors today that Joe that that Donnelly
Joe Donnelly from from Indiana who is a
Democrat is going to vote against it
there were rumors yesterday that
Donnelly was going to vote the same way
as Lisa Murkowski of Alaska Susan
Collins of Maine and Manchin of West
Virginia but none of that is clear at
this time so it is it is just not clear
at this time what is clear is that the
Democratic outrage over all of this is
just insane it is just insane Joe
philipovich who is a a feminist she's a
she wrote a book called the feminist
pursuit of happiness she literally wrote
a tweet this morning this has divorced
your Republican husband's divorce your
Republican husbands this is where the
Democrats are going their actual
implication here is that if you want
corroborate of evidence it's because you
hate women you don't care about the
accounts of women and you're fine
watching a rapist enter the Supreme
Court no one is fine watching a rapist
enter at the Supreme Court but we must
have corroborate of evidence for
allegations we can't just say that an
allegation on its own is enough to
destroy a man particularly when he gives
credible evidence on the other side it's
not that this woman it's not that clear
steam blaze before it has evidence and
then he has evidence that she has no
evidence and then he has evidence she
has no evidence every witness she says
was at the party denies that it ever
happened
denies remembering says we don't
remember this ever happening
her best friend Leland Kaiser came
forward and said that she doesn't even
know
Cavanagh and when asked about this
Christine Blasi Ford basically impeached
her own best friend say as witness
basically said my own best friend
doesn't know what she's talking about
she's a health problem I mean that's
pretty amazing stuff and we're just
going to ignore all that I also want to
talk in just a second about why
corroborate of evidence is necessary and
why the Democratic line that you must
believe all women is basically a load of
tripe we're going to talk about that in
just one second first let's talk about
the possibility of emergency I saw a
video from Indonesia today about a
tsunami hitting the ins in a small
Indonesian city is pretty shocking and
frightening and that's certainly true
emergencies can hit anywhere natural
disasters man-made emergencies and when
that happens you don't want to be left
without anything in your home you don't
want to be the guy who's trying to surf
through the streets to get to the
grocery store and the shelves are all
empty instead you should be prepared in
your home even the government says so go
check out my Patriots apply for
dependable food storage each person in
your household should have at least a
two-week emergency food supply from my
Patriot supply this week they're
offering a special price of only 75
bucks for a food kit that contains 92
servings of breakfasts lunches and
dinners call eight eight eight eight oh
three 14 13 or go to my special website
prepare with been calm the food lasts up
to 25 years in storage only 75 bucks
that includes a rugged tote as well
order now 888 803 1413 or prepare with
been calm that's prepared with been calm
888 803 1413 there's no power and
refrigeration fails and stores closed
you need to be prepared and your family
should be prepared as well go check it
out right now eight eight eight eight oh
three fourteen thirteen or prepare with
been calm so the left is basically
saying that if you don't quote unquote
believe all women this means that you're
a bad person
they don't believe all women no one
should believe all women because women
are not inherently more credible than
men they are not and victims by the way
are not always remembering things
properly so even if Christine blazing
Ford is telling the truth
we need corroborate of evidence because
there's just no way to tell there's no
way to tell it she made some statements
yesterday about the way the brain
chemistry works in the way that memory
works that are just flat-out wrong and
it's actually important to note these
things because this is why we need
corroborate of evidence this is why we
need some sort of detail we need
something that we can latch onto because
witness testimony or victim testimony
alone is not enough
it just isn't why because the data don't
back that
inertia was pointed this out yesterday
said there is no empirical evidence
supporting the gender-based political
view that women who claim to have been
sexually assaulted in alleged
acquaintance rape situations tell the
entire truth more often than men who are
accused and denied the accusation one
report from the US National Research
Council explains eyewitnesses are
notoriously unreliable quote unknown to
the individual memories are forgotten
reconstructed updated and distorted
Elizabeth Loftus who's a psychologist at
University of Washington says memories
are quote more easily modified for
instance when the passage of time allows
the original memory to fade
yes 36 years later false memories are
quote constructed by combining actual
memories but the content of suggestions
received from others in a small-scale
study the Loftus perform fully 25
percent of respondents remembered false
events constructed for them what about
the notion that Ford was promoting that
indelible impressions are left when you
experience a trauma research doesn't
back that idea according to a well cited
paper in nature findings from basic
psychological research and neuroscience
studies indicate memory is a
reconstructive process that is
susceptible to distortion furthermore
the commonly held belief among the
general public that an eyewitness's
confidence in the accuracy of his or her
memory is a strong indicator in the
actual accuracy of the memory is a myth
it's just not true it's not true that
because you believe that you're
remembering something accurately you are
actually believing something you're
remembering something accurately now
again maybe Ford is remembering this
accurately I don't know but you don't
know either and to simply say that
kristinb lazy Ford's memory is enough to
impeach and get rid of and destroy the
life of Judge Cavanaugh requires you to
throw out due process entirely that's
what it requires it requires an end to
due process and listen
Democrats were never interested in due
process from the very start of this they
were not interested at any point at any
point in due process and you can the
proof was in the pudding and so
Democrats in the committee hearing
yesterday were just abysmal first of all
if you thought this wasn't a circus if
you thought that this was folks taking
things seriously
why was Alyssa Milano there there were
only about 35 seats in the audience
apparently and yet right behind Brett
Kavanaugh there was actress Alyssa
Milano from charmed there she was
sitting right behind Brett Kavanaugh
look at her and she was sitting there
making faces the entire time on camera
behind Brett Kavanaugh why was she there
because
an feinstein invited her the same woman
who quote-unquote did not leak christine
Blasi ford's testimony and her letter to
the media the same woman who held that
letter for six weeks without actually
asking any serious questions about it
invited a famous actress to sit in at
the hearing specifically for publicity
purposes no this wasn't political at all
wasn't partisan hackery at all
speaking of partisan hackery sheldon
whitehouse making a complete ass of
himself you know the democrat senator
from Rhode Island AC starts asking Judge
Brett Kavanaugh yesterday about his
yearbook because this is what we need to
know we need to know whether there's
evidence from a yearbook that judge
Brett Kavanaugh was a serial rapist back
when he was in high school what is
Sheldon Whitehouse is evidence that
judge Brett Kavanaugh in his yearbook
used the word boof okay which means to
fart apparently this is what has become
of the world's greatest deliberative
body Sheldon Whitehouse making a
complete fool of himself
one is Sarah what do you have you I
don't know if it's buffed or boofed
how do you pronounce that I refers to
flatulence we were sixteen okay and so
when your friend mark judge said the
same put the same thing in his yearbook
page back to you he had the same meaning
it was flatulence I don't know what he
did but that's my recollection we want
to talk about flatulence at age sixteen
on a yearbook page um I'm game you
mentioned I think the Renata or Renee
Renata I don't know how you pronounce
that that's the proper name of an
individual you know Renata Renata okay
and then he just continued with this
line of questioning making a complete
idiot of himself but didn't stop there
Dianne Feinstein yesterday was put on
the defensive by Kavanagh it was one of
the great moments have seen in American
political life Feinstein who's been
slandering Kavanagh basically from the
bench I don't mean in the legal sense
but she's been saying things about
Kavanagh that are unbaked with
vindictive force she had to confront
Kavanaugh and Kavanagh basically
shredded her because there's one point
here at which Kavanagh was asked
specifically about the Julie sweat Nick
allegations clip five and she was asked
about he was asked about the the
allegations brought forward by Michael
avenatti that he was a gang rapists and
here's how one
for Diane Feinstein and and what you're
saying if if I understand it is that the
allegations by dr. Ford miss Ramirez and
miss faite that sweat Nick are are wrong
you that that is emphatically what I'm
saying
emphatically the sweat Nick thing is a
joke that is a farce would you like to
say more about it no and good for Brett
Kavanaugh if Einstein came out today and
she said I've never seen a nominee for
any position behave in that manner
judge Cavanaugh used as much political
rhetoric as my Republican colleagues
because you are all political hats who
tried to destroy his life that's why it
is perfectly appropriate for him to
fight back in preservation of his family
and his life
Feinstein by the way ended up dumping
her own witness under the bus she ended
up dumping Ford under the bus and she
was asked yesterday about how did all of
these letters end up in the possession
of the of the FBI in the media how did
the media get ahold of these letters
because remember originally Christine
Blasi Ford sent a letter to Dianne
Feinstein and said I want you to keep
this anonymous and Dianne Feinstein then
somehow magically disappears in the
media and sighin Feinstein says it
wasn't me it wasn't me so who was it if
it wasn't Feinstein there only two other
parties that had it and s you of
California representative and christine
blazing for herself but Ford has said
that she didn't leak this to the media
so here is Feinstein thumping forward
under the bus oh I don't believe my
staff would leak it I have not asked
that question directly but you do not oh
you know that but I mean how in the
world that get in the hands of the of
the press the answer is no the staff
have you ever asked you know have you
asked your staff or other staff dance or
the Judiciary Committee
pardon me well a Jennifers reminds me
I've asked her before about it well so
that's true well somebody leaked it if
it wasn't you well it was I'm telling
you it was not I did not I mean I was
asked to keep it confidential okay so
she says that she's it wasn't it that it
wasn't it wasn't her which means that it
was somebody on Ford's team so there she
is dumping her own witness under the bus
as a politically motivated actor who
wanted to get this stuff into the media
amazing amazing stuff well in just a
second we're gonna talk about the rest
of the Democratic response which it just
got worse from there it just got worse
from there this is a political crap show
of the highest order let me talk about
the rest of it why it's a sham why they
should hold the vote yesterday why they
should be done already but first let's
talk about your second Amendment rights
if you trust these jokers to protect
your second Amendment rights you are out
of your mind these are folks you don't
give a damn about any of your rights but
you should and that's why you should be
a member of the u.s. CCA right now the
u.s. ECA is giving away a free critical
self-defense Survival Guide and you can
finally learn what to do when the smoke
clears in case god forbid you actually
have to use your gun in self-defense
because you may be hailed as a hero or
you may be treated as a criminal knowing
exactly what you should and should not
say to the police couldn't mean the
difference between freedom or jail you
can claim your free copy in seconds and
for a limited time you'll also get a
deadly force checklist just text the
word go to the number eight seven two
two two to get yours right now again
text the word go to eight seven two two
two to get that free critical
self-defense Survival Guide and as an
added bonus you'll hear true stories of
survival with their brand-new shocking
true stories of self-defense an audio
book that's three life saving tools
right now go check it out 100% free only
available to my listeners until next
week text go to 8 7 2 2 2 right now
that's go to 8 7 2 2 2 right now and
again you get that free critical
self-defense Survival Guide the deadly
force checklist and the shocking truth
stories of self-defense audiobook a lot
of good stuff plus you should be a
member of the US ECA anyway they're
doing great work text go to 8 7 2 2 2 go
check it out right now
I've never seen a spectacle quite like
what we are seeing today we've seen
protesters inhabit the halls of the
Senate we saw protesters screaming at
Jeff Flake Jeff Flake is one of the most
moderate members of the United States
Senate he said that he's gonna vote for
Brett Kavanaugh specifically because
there's no corroborate of evidence to
rule Brett Kavanaugh eff out he was
confronted in elevators and told that he
hates women doesn't care about women
doesn't care if women get raped
absolutely a lie absolutely a sham
really disgusting and you can see the
Democratic rhetoric escalating now you
could see it happening yesterday when
the Democrats it turned out had nothing
it turns out they had no actual facts to
back the allegations made by Christine
Blasi Ford they had no specific
questions that they asked Brett
Kavanaugh none of that instead they just
kept begging Kavanagh over and over to
call
an FBI investigation into himself the
real reason that he won't do that is
because he understands as does everyone
else
the only reason Democrats are calling
for an FBI investigation is because it
will take minimum a couple of months
which brings us beyond the election
which is all the Democrats want they
just want this push it off beyond the
election so that there can be a new
Senate that is impaneled at which point
Kavanagh doesn't get approved
even if he's innocent and then they just
hold the seat open until after Trump is
president that is their entire goal here
as Lindsey Graham said but here was
Kamala Harris and Dick Durbin pretending
that it was really all just about why
won't you ask for an FBI investigation
here's why this is so stupid here's what
an FBI investigation does they ask a
bunch of witnesses a bunch of questions
those are sworn oaths right under a 302
you know who else can do that
members of the Senate they can get
people to testify and they don't need
majority help Kamala Harris can ask for
the testimony of Marc judge now in fact
they were lying yesterday Democrats said
Republicans haven't talked to Marc judge
lies Republicans did talk to Marc judge
Democrats boycotted the actual hearing
with Marc judge not a hearing but the
actual interview with Marc judge because
they didn't want to lend credibility to
the actual interview with Marc judge
this is all political gamesmanship of
the most disgusting magnitude
here's Kamala Harris though who wants to
run for president in 2020 she walked out
of the Judiciary Committee vote this
morning and she held hands with mazie
Hirono because women unites here was
Harris yesterday pressing on the FBI
investigation point the FBI would gather
witness statements you have I don't want
to debate with you how they do their
business
I'm just asking are you willing to ask
the White House to conduct such an
investigation the witness testimonies
before you no witness who was there
supports that I was there okay I'm gonna
take that as a no and we can move on
okay I'm gonna take that as a no that
you're not gonna call for an FBI
investigation he doesn't have the power
to initiate an FBI investigation the
Senate has investigative powers the
Senate Judiciary Committee has the power
to investigate that's why Ford was there
yesterday under oath this whole thing is
ridiculous
it got even more ridiculous though
because it didn't stop there Brett
Kavanaugh responded angrily when he was
accused of rape whoo that's bad
he can't respond angrily when he is
accused of rape instead he's
to respond with a completely placid
demeanor at which point Democrats call
him robotic and a fake that's how this
is supposed to work and Brett Kavanaugh
gets angry it's because he's guilty and
if he doesn't get angry it's also
because he's guilty ted Lieu essentially
tweeted that out yesterday our execrable
Congress person from here in California
he tweeted out if Brett Kavanaugh can be
this angry on national TV
imagine what he's like when he gets
inebriated so in other words I accuse
you of rape you get angry that means
you're probably an angry drunk that
probably means 36 years ago you raped a
girl that's the chain of logic there
that is the chain of logic being used by
a sitting Congress person and it wasn't
just Ted Lou it was ridiculous disgrace
brian schatz the senator from Hawaii he
tweeted out it's hard to imagine this
person being objective and fair on the
Supreme Court is it though he spent
years on the DC Circuit Court of Appeals
is it possible you might be pissed if I
accused you of rape is it possible you
might not appear objective and fair if I
accused you of rape and you came back at
me and said you're you're a bleep what
but you're not being objective and fair
to me right because you just accused me
of rape it's probably that and it wasn't
just those eight Senator Jeff Merkley
his 26 Jeff Merkley tweeted something
similar out
he said Brett Kavanaugh showed himself
today to be a partisan hack in a robe
utterly lacking the temperament to be a
Justice of the Supreme Court and his
repeated refusal to request an FBI
investigation speaks volumes a partisan
hack in a robe again you'd have
something in his actual record to
support that if you cared to look but
instead you're just gonna call him a
partisan hack after it I mean this is
this is gaslighting at its finest this
is when you have a younger sibling and
you take your younger siblings hand and
you hit your younger sibling in the face
and go stop hitting yourself stop
hitting yourself stop hitting yourself
this is exactly what Democrats are doing
here Democrats are saying you are a gang
rapist you are a you are a an alleged
rapist of a 15 year old girl 36 years
ago at an unnamed party in an unnamed
location and an unnamed date that's you
and then if you get mad that just shows
you a partisan hack if you say the
year-old that I'm only doing that for
partisan purposes well that shows that
you sir are the real partisan you wonder
why people are going nuts because you're
gaslighting them which is deliberately
designed to make people go nuts
that's what gas lighting is gas lighting
is where you tell some somebody
something not true and then when they
respond to the untruth you blame them
for responding to the untruth that's
what's going on here i honest-to-god
democrats stoop pretty low sometimes but
to protect abortion which is what this
is really about this is as low as I've
ever seen anyone stoop anyone Kristin
Gillibrand comes forward who as you will
recall said that if Brett Kavanaugh
doesn't call for an FBI investigation of
himself that means he's guilty she came
forward and she says she was offended
how Cavanaugh spoke to senators so she
proclaims that he is basically a rapist
and then she comes forward and says
she's offended by his response
honest to god if I'd been Brett
Kavanaugh yesterday I would have come in
birds flying I mean I would have just
flipped off the entire I would have
walked in there and flipped them off I
would have dropped eighty thousand eight
f-bombs I would have I would have been
so much more colorful than Brett
Kavanaugh was yesterday the fact that
Brett cab knows is contained as he was
is a shock it's a shock but Kirsten
Gillibrand says no one should treat
senators this way and I hide behind that
senator title after slandering about
amazing stuff
the way he talked he was so arrogant and
how he spoke to senators and and
dismissive I was I was really offended
by how he behaved at the hearing oh no
we're not offended by Kristin Gillibrand
we're not offended by Dianne Feinstein
hiding a story of rape for six weeks so
that she could get away with pushing
Brett Kavanaugh off the court just
absurd just absurd okay the the most
absurd of course is from ex Senator
Barbara Boxer who used to be officially
the stupidest woman in the United States
Senate and she now she's no longer in
the United States Senate she's been
replaced by Kamala Harris and soon as a
running gun battle for stupidest woman
in the United States Senate who may not
in fact be stupidest person in the
United States Senate Sheldon Whitehouse
is definitely up for that honor but in
any case Barbara Boxer who used to be
the stupidest woman in the United States
Senate she says that Brett Kavanaugh you
could actually see him attacking a woman
because he was sitting there getting
angry that people were accusing him of
attacking a woman all of a sudden we see
a man transformed from a choirboy who up
to now has said after hours in further
committee he lived this very
perfect life all of a sudden his anger
is triggered and what we saw today is
someone who you could now see attacking
a woman it's very frightening yes and
that was clearly what happened there if
I accuse you of rape and you get mad
then clearly you're a person or the kind
of person who would attack a woman I
mean this is legitimately a witch-hunt
kind of thing this is legitimately a if
you we throw you in the river and you
sink that means you were innocent and if
you float that means you're guilty and
we burn you at the stake
that's what this is if he gets mad it's
because he's guilty if he doesn't get
mad it's because he's insincere what's
even worse than the Democrats you can
expect to do all this sort of nonsense
are the members of the media I mean the
media coverage of this was just
egregious they are so partisan they're
so open in their partisanship it is
truly an astonishing astonishing thing
to watch and and the mask is off I mean
you wonder why I hope Republicans
turnout is amazing in six weeks I hope
Republican turnout is just unending I
hope you bring all your friends to vote
because these folks cannot have power
these folks cannot be given power if
these folks have power they will use it
to run you and your rights off the
ground that is what they are doing here
they were willing to destroy a man's
life and family based on an unverifiable
allegation what do you think they're
willing to do to you for political gain
what do you think they're willing to do
to your rights for political gain is the
most cynical partisan disgusting hacker
I've ever seen in my entire life it's
just abysmal and the media complicit in
it at every step of the way because the
media have demonstrated that they are in
fact democratic outlets I'm a guy who's
criticized President Trump for saying
that the media are fake news but Ted
this week they proved that they were
partisan hacks in objected news
journalists sheep's clothing they showed
it over and over again I'll explain in
just a second but first you're gonna
have to go over to Daley wire and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you can get
a subscription the daily wire means you
get the rest of the show live the rest
of mandrill Clavin shall live the rest
of michael mosley show live the rest of
Matt Walsh is show live all sorts of
goodies plus you get to be part of the
mailbag yesterday we did a second live
show and I took questions from our
subscribers only you can do that sort of
thing if you are a subscriber so go
check it out right now also subscribe at
YouTube or iTunes and that ensures that
you're going to be able to actually get
our Sunday special which you who it's
Cameron Cassie this Sunday
we have a bunch of great ones coming up
as well so go check that out we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
I'm gonna show you some of the media
treatments of all of this now we're
gonna start with some of the quote
unquote objective media and then we'll
get to the non objective media because
the non objective media are democrat
hacks are basically democrat hacks and i
won't to discuss their point of view but
let's start with the folks who are
supposed to be objective so we begin
with john king of CNN so john king of
CNN yesterday he comes out he says Brent
Cavanaugh went full Trump which is the
worst thing you can say about anyone on
CNN he went full Trump or alternatively
Brett Kavanaugh was legitimately
defending himself against charges that
he believes are false against him but if
you're angry at any point then you're
trumpian and if you're not angry it's
because you're not authentic authentic
emotion my favorite meme this way today
was was Maggie Haberman over at the New
York Times Maggie Haberman the New York
Times tweeted something out like if you
had ever seen a Democrat get angry and
upset and yelling and crying and being
mean with senators if you've ever seen a
Democratic woman like that they would
have been run out of town on a rail
really I remember someone named Hillary
Clinton who went in front of the Senate
Committee on Benghazi and stand and said
that she didn't really matter right what
difference does it make how things went
down in Benghazi what difference does it
make why the protest happened in the
first place yelling at senators being as
militant and nasty as humanly possible
and the Democrats cheered her still she
persisted it's just nonsense but here is
John King doing the same routine Brett
Kavanaugh is obviously just like Donald
Trump the implication being of course
that he's just as guilty as Donald Trump
I'm mad or sexual Brett Kavanaugh went
full Trump today and does that appeal to
them or does it repulse them and if
because they don't like Trump they don't
the read that of those four key senators
they are repulsed not only by this
president by how he conducts himself by
his history so does Cavanaugh's embrace
of Trump help him just it just insane
John Bresnahan of Politico a supposedly
objective journalist over at political
he tweets out this indignant angry
attitude is not good for Kavanagh really
isn't it and then we had the Washington
brian Stelter right it's supposedly
objective journalist on CNN he quotes a
piece from The Washington Post today in
America this was men against women right
against left a cascade of recrimination
explosions of anger hours of tears and
sobs wasn't men against women or is that
the narrative the medium wants to
portray
my producer Senya turns out she is a
woman okay and my producer Sonya was
miffed yesterday
I mean angry yesterday over the
treatment of Brett Kavanaugh and I
honestly I've rarely seen so many
Republican women angry at the treatment
of anyone we have a lot of women who
work in this office a lot of women who
work in this office they were glued to
the screen and they were indignant at
the way Brett Kavanaugh was treated
yesterday because it turns out a lot of
these women have husbands have sons a
lot of them are looking at the way men
are being treated by the militant
feminists and the and the radical
members of the meets who movement and
they're saying I can't live in a country
like this I want people protected yes I
like men and I want men protected too
they are still American citizens even if
they have penises it turns out there are
a lot of women who still believe in due
process and the rights of the accused
there's still a lot of women don't like
to watch partisan hackery substituted
for any sort of knowledge it's just it's
an amazing thing the Washington Post had
this headline Cavanagh sexual assault
hearing turns partisan as Republican
senators lash out a treatment of Supreme
Court nominee
I wasn't partisan before that it wasn't
partisan when Dianne Feinstein held up
an actual accusation of alleged rape
back in 1982 for six weeks for her own
purposes
now it's partisan only now it got
partisan you know this is the famous
Republicans pounce meme that you see
from the media all the time every time
Democrats do something bad when
Republicans respond it's Republicans
pounce and NBC News tweeted this this
was their headline conservative media
dedicate blanket coverage to for
adhering how is that even a headline 30
million people watched the hearing
yesterday everyone dedicated blanket
coverage to Ford hearing I for example
was watching some of the coverage on
MSNBC it turns out everyone's dedicated
blanket coverage to the Ford hearing
these are the objective news media and
then we get to the complete fools in the
quantum quote non objective news media
these people be like Luke Russert Luke
Russert tweeted this out say he tweeted
out oh boy Cavanaugh is going full angry
belittled marginalized white man tough
sell for today or alternatively he
believes who's falsely accused of an
attempted rape and he was mad about it
but no he's white so he can't talk he's
a man so he can't talk basically he's
supposed to sit there and take all this
I can't
to show you what Jennifer Rubin had to
say you know get to that in just a
second so Jennifer Rubin is the
quote-unquote conservative columnist
over at the Washington Post which is
just absurd I think they recently
finally changed that because it is
obvious that Jennifer Rubin is the hack
of all hacks if you go back and look at
what she wrote about Mitt Romney in 2012
versus what she has written about Mitt
Romney today she's reversed herself on
virtually every position because Trump
legitimately drove her out of her mind
and she proved that with this tweet
yesterday quote with him screaming and
interrupting senators I could imagine
him putting his hand over someone's
mouth yes you see he was mean to
senators calling him a rapist and that
means that you can imagine him putting
his hand over a woman's mouth while
attempting to rape her well weird
because after reading that tweet I can
imagine Jennifer Rubin ranting in an
insane asylum and someone tries to catch
her with a butterfly net as she runs
around in a straitjacket doesn't take
much of a leap for me to get there
actually but this was this was the
entire stick up and down yesterday over
and over yesterday and then you finally
get to the real nub of the matter and
the nub of the matter I think was
brought forth by Stephen Colbert so
Stephen Colbert has given up comedy now
he just does unfunny political
commentary yeah ima I am a political
commentator who is at moments funny
Stephen Colbert basically is now in my
Lane right he used to be a comedian who
sometimes political now he's a political
commentator who's occasionally funny
here he was yesterday being completely
unfunny about the Cavanaugh hearings but
spilling the beans on what the real
agenda here is for Democrats the wind
was sown when Donald Trump had 19
credible allegations of sexual assault
against him bragged about sexual assault
on tape and your Republican buddies up
on that committee said yeah but we want
our guy on the Supreme Court and that's
you Brett that doesn't mean you're
guilty but please save your indignation
that finally someone is taking one
woman's accusation of sexual assault
seriously okay so I mean that's an
amazing statement so Brett Kavanaugh has
no right to be outraged none no right to
be outraged because people didn't take
the allegations against Trump seriously
so in other words Republicans voted for
Trump despite the allegations that means
that if we leverage completely
charges evidence free charges except for
the allegation itself if we leverage
those allegations against Cavanaugh he
has no right to be mad because
Republicans weren't mad when actual
charges were levered a leverage against
Trump he understands her Trump was
guilty therefore Cavanaugh shouldn't be
mad that he's being railroaded what in
the how is that how is that even
remotely logical it isn't and he got
shares for it he got cheers for it all
this is a petty revenge play people are
angry that Trump is president people are
angry the Merrick garland isn't on the
court people are angry that there will
be five Republican people who Republican
appointed conservatives on the court
they're upset about that and therefore
they are fine with anything that gets
thrown at these guys anything is a show
trial this is a Dreyfus Affair type
thing for folks who don't know the
Dreyfus Affair back in that 1892 France
there was an attempt by French
nationalists to railroad a member of the
French military named Alfred Dreyfus a
Jew is an anti-semitic attempt to
suggest that he was funneling documents
to the austro-hungarian Empire he was
not but it turned into a cause celeb
anyway a political purposes in fact
infect situations like this and it is
obvious that for Democrats it has
infected situations like this it's just
it's maddening it's maddening and that's
why Republicans are saying just vote on
this thing you know what done let's vote
on this let's be done with this I'm sick
of it it doesn't matter what you do you
can have an FBI hearing tomorrow
everybody could testify to exactly the
same thing they've already testified to
everybody could already come forward and
say that Cavanaugh is completely
innocent
we can do all of that any of it and all
of it we could do and it wouldn't matter
one damn for these Democrats wouldn't
matter one one iota for the one atom for
these Democrats and nothing they would
not care all this is about is petty
revenge and if they have to tear down a
man based on a bunch of fraudulent
allegations and a credible allegation
with no corroborate of evidence they
will do it they will do it they will do
it to anyone if they'll do it to Brett
Kavanaugh they'll do it to you they'll
do it to me they will do it to anyone
and it's amazing there there are so many
people out there who are saying we need
a new unity in this country you can't
have unity when you don't have basic
agreement on standards of due process I
mean these are the basics of Western
civilization and we are seeing them
thrown out in favor of sheer hard
and brutality on the part of the left
I've roped it when I've seen it from the
right I ripped it when I saw the the
associations of the alt-right of the
Trump campaign and I will rip it when I
see it from the left and today what
you're seeing is the mainstream
Democratic Party embracing their worst
instincts embracing the worst angels of
their nature The Devil's of their nature
in order to get what they want and it is
it is disgusting an awe-inspiring to
watch it is it is just incredible no
matter no wonder so many people are
angry vote on Kavanagh put them on the
Supreme Court and let's be done with
this sham let's do it now
alrighty so it'll do a few questions
from the mailbag since we sort of ran
out of time on the mailbag but we'll do
a few questions for our subscribers
anyway so Alexander asks Shalom is the
intellectual dark web you Rogan Rubin
Harris hoff sommers brothers Weinstein
sufficient to develop a real
well-rounded worldview after watching
your take on the Cavanaugh hearing I
wanted to get another viewpoint from the
left just to balance things out
unfortunately what I found that was that
every left-leaning source him deeply
pretentious thumbing their nose at facts
while championing subjective feelings
specifically NPR pod save America The
Young Turks basically I feel myself
becoming more and more partisan and I
wanted to know if I should just let it
happen
or keep fighting for some kind of middle
ground thanks for everything you do well
you know this is an interesting question
because they're a bunch of people on the
intellectual dark web particularly Sam
Harris and Eric Weinstein who disagree
with me sharply on Kavanagh I actually
had an exchange with Sam Harris on
Twitter yesterday about Kavanagh what
the intellectual dark web is good for is
the idea that we can actually have
conversations about difficult topics but
it does not mean we agree on things it
does not mean we agree on things not by
a longshot
I have significant disagreements with
Sam Harris I have significant
disagreements with Eric Weinstein that's
fine all of that is good all of that is
okay the purpose of the intellectual
dark web is to provide a forum for well
reasons and argued conversations and
that I think is useful does that mean
that partisan differences go away no but
the difference between the partisans of
the IDW I hope and people who are
outside the IDW is the people inside the
IDW are trying not to make
intellectually incoherent arguments with
that said if you're looking for a
coherent worldview from the IDW I don't
think that's I think that's asking too
much I don't think that's what this is I
think that the dark web is like any
other forum I think it is more of a
forum with a few values in common like
belief in free speech and a huge variety
of differences
matter substantive and I think people
ought to keep that in mind it's not like
we all get together and we agree on
everything or even close to it
Nicole says please enlighten me as to
how you keep your emotions in check
during this despicable circus my blood
is boiling but I try to stay quiet
because I know if I speak up I will
probably blow with anger Thank You
Nicole listen I'm having a tough time
I'll be honest with you I mean this is
the most emotional I've felt about
politics in a long time and that is just
because it is exactly as you call it a
despicable circus hey I think that
keeping your emotions in check is mostly
a matter of being at a remove it's hard
to be in a remove when you watch people
make intellection not only
intellectually in coherent arguments but
morally despicable arguments jill
philipovich delete you divorce your
Republican husbands honestly gentlemen
don't marry radical feminists in the
first place that is the proper response
to that but I mean how do you keep your
emotions in check
that's right listen I'm a human being
just like anybody else I try to present
as many facts as I can I hope that those
facts are convincing to you I'm not
gonna pretend I don't get emotional
about subjects but I hope that those
emotions are not just positive because I
don't think that emotions should be
dispositive House has been what are your
biggest pet peeves besides your wife
losing her phone yeah I know I got a lot
of play off of that story about my wife
losing her phone and that is definitely
that is definitely one of them the truth
is that most pet peeves are my own fault
I think it's mostly stuff where I have
expectations of people and the
expectations are unjustified my wife
losing her phone is probably the biggest
one honestly I'm trying I'm trying to
think of other pet peeves I mean
obviously like their moral pet peeves
that I've just pet peeves with politics
in general I have pet peeves with
Twitter I have pet peeves with social
media but in terms of kind of
interpersonal relations okay so a couple
of them when people say can I just have
a minute of your time and I'm in the
middle of work that's a pet peeve
because the answer is no you can't
because it's not actually a minute it's
more like 15 I've said this before it
takes me seven minutes to get out of
what I'm doing seven minutes get back
into what I'm doing and it's a problem
and so that one is not great the the
let's see other ones interpersonally if
I so there are times where I will ask my
wife I need like 15 minutes to do
something can you watch the kids and
she'll be doing her best and she'll be
watching one and then my two and
son comes busting through the door now
Colton's sitting in the room holding the
scene my two and a half year old son my
two and a half year old son is a nut
okay my two and a half year old son he's
the most charming beautiful wonderful
kid and he is totally crazy he's totally
a crazy person Colton was on a flight
from Sacramento to LA with me and my two
kids and my wife because he just ended
up on the same flight back the other day
and he watched as my son lost his bleep
for a full 35 minutes on the descent
into Los Angeles because he wouldn't sit
his little ass down in the buckle he
just wouldn't he stood up he was trying
to stand it cuz he was obsessed with the
lights above the above the seats and he
and he actually would take down the the
tray table and then he would stand on
the tray table and then hit all the
buttons and then he'd get mad if you
took him down and he would scream like a
banshee and then and my wife would try
to appease him by giving him chocolates
you know he's covered in chocolate and
he's got his hands all full of chocolate
and he's struggling against me and it'll
suck her strong and he's like a ball of
muscle and you're trying to muscle him
into his seat as he is screaming I said
he doesn't I'm like kid you're gonna
like if we crash well you're gonna die
like just sit down just sit down you
can't reason with two and a half year
old in any case sometimes my wife loses
containments of the children the
quarantine ends and I'm sitting in the
library working and suddenly it could
bust through the door and just jumps on
my back and it's too cute for my wife to
do anything about it but I actually need
her to do something about it and it
doesn't happen so that that is a pet
peeve but that's honestly not her fault
it happens sometimes again most
disappointments and pet peeves come from
you have a having expectations of other
people that are unfulfilled one solution
is to not have expectations of other
people that are unjustified Polly says
dear Ben if Kavanaugh backs down from
the court position or is found unfit do
you think Amy Barrett if nominated will
be attacked like him for being a
Christian and pro-life or do you think
people go back off because she's a woman
no they'll murder her
they'll murder her they'll send her to
the murder hole that's what will happen
everybody knew this going in which is
why I said he should nominate a Kony
Barrett she was the most right-wing
choice that I could see the most
constitutionalist choice that I could
see and I wanted to see them attack a
woman for her Catholic beliefs a mother
of seven who sits on a federal circuit
court I thought that had been a lot
better optics that said should Cavanaugh
be seated of course he should be seated
Blake says hey Ben you noted the
possibility of a civil war in the next
50 to 100 years do you think the
timeline is sped up after these hearings
thank you for all you do god bless it's
hard not to
feel like the timeline is sped up right
I mean it looks like now like would you
be surprised if tomorrow a senator gets
shot in the direction building would
that be completely surprising to you in
the aftermath of all these protesters
who are showing up and screaming at
people and getting in their face and
throwing Ted Cruz out of restaurants
would it be totally I mean we had
baseball we had a bunch of Congress
people shot last year would it be all
that shocking if somebody shot a senator
or tried to take a pot shot at president
Trump would that be completely shocking
I don't think so the real question is
whether there are massive leftists who
are actually willing to get violent like
a real massive leftist willing to get
violent my inclination so far is know
that it's a lot of talk but that sort of
thing can change over time and it can
certainly change from the other point of
view if Democrats ever get in charge of
power and they start trying to say take
away guns in Texas things could get
violent very quickly in this country if
they start telling religious people that
religious people have to shut down their
schools shut down their churches because
they won't abide by social structures
promulgated by the left things could get
really bad really fast so yeah I mean
it's hard not to watch this week and
feel like we're five seconds from chaos
john-michael says hey Ben
not the Democrats are interested in
anything other than delay are there are
mechanisms are there mechanisms for
delaying elections in the United States
if the elections were delayed would you
support a more thorough investigation
into Cavanaugh not really I mean I don't
know what a more thorough investigation
looks like he's had six FBI background
checks at this point all the people who
have been questioned have been
questioned I don't mind a more thorough
investigation but if time were not a
consideration would I have liked
significant objections to an FBI
investigation probably not but it's also
at this point a balancing act between
the fact I don't think an FBI
investigation is likely to do anything
and the fact that the reason Democrats
are calling for it is specifically so it
doesn't do anything okay final question
here Christopher says you said
corroborating evidence at least a dozen
times in the last episode what exactly
would such evidence look like in the
case of dr. Ford's accusation okay
here's what it would look like it would
look like clay she says there were four
boys and one other girl there it would
look like any of those four people
saying this happened
that's what corroborating evidence would
look like it would look like somebody
saying yeah I picked her up from a party
she was crying and hysterical it would
look like somebody saying I dropped her
off at the party it would look like
somebody saying yeah she told me about
it the next day it was really awful it
would look like her saying anything for
30 years any shred of cobber
eminence I heard about a party that
happened and something really went wrong
and I heard Ford was there I heard
Cavanaugh is there like anything there's
not one shred of corroborate of evidence
nothing we don't even know that house
where this took place I mean this is
that's what I mean by corroborate of
evidence I don't think any of those
things are too much to ask by the way
every single allegation made about
Cavanaugh at this point supposedly
happening in public right supposedly
happen in a public setting with other
witnesses not one witness has come
forward and said they saw this stuff
happen not one that's kind of telling
already so time for a quick thing I like
and then anything I hate and then we
will break for the weekend now I gotta
warn you guys next week
final Jewish holidays I promise I
promise God's calendar finally coming to
an end and so I am off Monday and
Tuesday for the last time this year
until Christmas break alright so just
the morning now so listen to this
episode three times because basically I
don't know that much is gonna change
except I think have and I'll probably
get confirmed but we'll be back here
next Wednesday but here's it let's do
some things I like and some things oh
yeah and also you can check out what I
think on Sunday because we're doing the
the Ben Shapiro election special on Fox
News so if you miss me that much we have
a Sunday special on Sunday and the Ben
Shapiro election special on Sunday on
Fox News so you won't miss me that much
I'll only be gone for a couple of days
but let's do a thing I like in a thing
that I hate so here's here's the thing
that I like today the there's a it's not
a great movie but it's a fun movie the
movie is sensible woman with Al Pacino
it is it is
Al Pacino at his Pacino IIST say Al
Pacino's started off as a good actor and
then he just became Al Pacino so if you
watch him in The Godfather he's actually
subtle and then about halfway through
his career he was like you know what
screw saddle this is just not a thing
I'm interested in it happens with a lot
of actors where they fall in love with
the with the actor enos of them or
suddenly they turn into Jon Lovitz
acting and Al Pacino definitely does
that he won an Oscar for this which is
kind of ridiculous but the movie itself
is kind of fun it's really stupid but
it's kind of fun the basic premise is
that Chris O'Donnell plays a kid in a
prep school and a couple of his
classmates play a prank on the
headmaster and he's asked about he won't
rat on them and he is tasked with
driving around this blind general to
kind of his final wishes before this
blind general is going to commit suicide
that's that's basically the plot of the
movie
and there's only one scene that it comes
to mind this week and that is there's a
scene near the end of the movie where Al
Pacino is testifying on behalf of this
kid they basically have a hearing into
the prank and now Pacino basically goes
off on the school and it's pretty
reminiscent of kind of what happened in
court yesterday with within the
Judiciary Committee with with Kavanagh
anyway here's a little preview
hi mr. Joshi heard about the weekend job
[Music]
gentleman a real hero
this is some guy down deep the man is a
lumber sure what do you mean what I want
what do you want here
I want I want a job a job come on easy
sell that you know Al Pacino um it's
it's the movie is fun it's worth
watching okay time for a quick thing
that I hate because I hate everything
this week so and so Hillary Clinton is
irrelevant
no one cares about her she was a
terrible candidate she is not a good
human in my opinion and Hillary Clinton
is being brought back by the folks at
NBC for a cameo on a show that never
should have been remade namely this on
CBS or NBC its CBS CBS the show is
Murphy Brown I don't know why we are
bringing back Murphy Brown we've run out
of all ideas so Candice Bergen who is
now approximately 97 years old he's back
in the starring role as Murphy Brown
when in reality this would never happen
because let's be real about the news
industry and CBS and NBC they fire every
woman at 60 except for Barbara Walters I
mean this is the the like first problem
I'm having a tough time with the
believability in any case Murphy Brown
is there and she and and suddenly
Hillary Clinton shows up to interview as
her secretary this is maybe the most
spine-chilling ly boring segment of
television you have ever seen and it
reminds you why Hillary Clinton is not
president because my god woman is
somebody who has no capacity to act I
mean I I'm an awful actor it'sit's a
joke around the office every time we cut
a promo
every time we every time we do a bit we
have to cut around man like a child
actor we take like seven takes of me and
then we cut it in right so that it said
that oh look it's a reaction shot right
it said it really is that bad I'm an
awful awful actor so I speak from
experience Hillary Clinton makes me look
like Laurence Olivier I mean she is just
I'm like Daniel day-lewis compared to
this lady she is just astonishingly
awful here she is doing alleged comedy
alleged comedy with with count with
Candice Bergen and Murphy oh my goodness
I guess you've heard this is a pretty
demanding job I have your reputation
precedes you but I want you to know I am
not afraid of hard work I'm qualified
and ready on day one and I also assumed
you've had previous secretarial
experience elute lee for four years I
was a secretary I was Terry of a very
large organization and you have all the
requisite skills computer email emails I
I do have some experience with email let
me give you my card thank you Thank You
Hillary
and you could have had me calm okay
worst cameo I have ever seen in my life
well she she has no sense of timing Lee
it's not that the dialogue is bad
because if she actually had a sense of
timing then it might be funny but her
sense of timing is basically she just
says a line she is it she's the most
mechanical she's most mechanical
candidate she's a mechanical actor it
reminds us why she's not president which
I'm very thankful for I can't say our
country is is in good shape but I can
still say at least she's not president
right I mean oh yeah okay well we will
be back here on Wednesday again watch
the Fox News Sunday special our Fox News
Sunday special which is the the Ben
Shapiro election special on Fox it's at
5:00 p.m. Pacific 8:00 p.m. Eastern go
check that out on Sunday in case you're
gonna miss me too much over the weekend
otherwise we'll see you back here on
Wednesday we'll see you then try not to
ruin things further I mean God if I come
back after the holiday and the world is
just on fire well I guess that would be
like a normal Wednesday around here
we'll be back there - then I'm Ben
Shapiro this is Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018